[Music]
after seven years of life upon the
ocean it is time to bid the seven sees
farewell and the city I've pinned seven
years of hopes on lies just over the
horizon I can hear the harbor
Bell
[Music]
land got a Ted over coat and battered
suitcase got a pair of leaky boots upon
my feet sorry cook got to drug myself up
by my one good boot lace got to work my
rotten socks off if I want to make ends
meat I've poured everything I've got
into my
chocolate now it's time to show the
world my recipes good I've got 12 silver
SS in my
pocket and a half full of dream
there's a famous restaurant on every
street here there's brandino and the bar
Paris rest M thank you got a little map
to tell me where to eat here had a dozen
silver sovereigns now I'm somehow down
to 10 want the finest produce this is
where they St it that's three sovereigns
mate though the prices are suspiciously
extreme my pumpkin you pay for it I've
got five six
seven six silver SS in my
pocket and a hat full of Dreams Rush a
coat sir no thank you colog no leave me
alone at last the gallery
garade
I knew that we'd see it one
day it's everything you said Mama and oh
so much more each way that you turn
another famous chocolate store here's my
destiny I just need to unlock it will I
crash and burn or go up like a
rocket I got nothing to offer but my
chocolate and a
had full of
[Music]
Dreams no
daydreaming in this city anyone can be
success
uccessful if they've talent and work
hard or so they
say but they didn't mention it would be
so
stressful just to make azen silver sovs
last more than a
day could you spare a sovereign for a
place to sleep love of course here take
all you need thank you I've got one
silver Sovereign in my
pocket and a hatful
of
dream
there we go time for a little night
[Music]
capap hello there stop hey hey shoe go
away stop go away Sho Sho stop
sit sorry about titles seems to have an
unusual interest in your legs must be
these pants I got them from a mailman in
Minsk that would be it tiddles would
spend all day pursuing postal workers if
he could wouldn't you
boy you're not planning on sleeping
there are you son no it's just for a
night
by this time tomorrow I plan to have
made my fortune by this time tomorrow
you'll be frozen solid oh don't be
ridiculous Perhaps it is a little cold
for camping but unfortunately I'm not in
a position to pay for a room sir oh I'm
sorry to hear that but as luck would
have it I know someone who might be able
to help you out
really here we are Mr Wonka I'm straet
home
get your fky balls off my front door you
Mindy mat if I you bleach you better up
My Gin oh I have something better than
gin Mrs scrub
it a
guest oh what didn't you
say hang on in sir welcome to scrub it
and bleachers guest out and laundry make
yourself at home warm your cockles by
the fire Jin oh no out yes Mrs scrubb it
put that book down and get our guest a
glass of gin po man's Frozen after death
thank you Mrs scrubb it and your husband
have been so kind to me husband
him oh you'd love that would you oh I'm
holding out for someone far superior to
that Idol peasant Chin
Chin that is extremely strong stuff yeah
you can run cars on it so what is it I
can do for your room is it
well yes but uh Mr Wonker is temporarily
embarrassed oh no you don't s I'm afraid
that's true Mrs scrubb but all that's
about to change oh yeah you see I'm
something of a magician inventor and
chocolate maker and first thing tomorrow
at the gallery Gourmet I plan to unveil
my most astonishing creation yet prepare
to be amazed as I present to
you a taper
no that's just for making tea one
second that's for my
stew it's in here somewhere don't you
worry Mr Wonker I can see you're a man
of great Ingenuity and we've got just
the thing for you the entrepreneurial
package now the room is One Sovereign a
night but you don't have to pay till
6:00 tomorrow does that give you enough
time to earn a few pennies more than
enough Mr scrubby thank you oh it's the
least I can do for a stranger in need
now sign here and we're all done
all
righty read the small print what thank
you no that do oh what' you say who's
that in the girl what girl that girl is
sounded like read the small print and
there does seem to be a lot of oh oh oh
oh oh oh just keeps on coming yeah you
don't want to listen to n Mr wos is
damaged damaged orphan syndrome orphan
syndrome orphan syndrome orphan syndrome
she was dropped down the laundry shoot
as a bab and I took her in at the
goodness of my art and I've done my best
Mr Wonka honest I have but she's been
left with a suspicious nature she sees
conspiracy everywhere poor girl I know
these are just your standard T's and C's
but you're welcome to take a look if you
want I'll just give it one
over